a couple of videos ago we saw that in
just classic c3 photosynthesis and once
again it's called c3 because the first
time that carbon is fixed it's fixed
into a three or the first time carbon
dioxide is fixed it's fixed into a three
carbon molecule but we saw the problem
with c3 photosynthesis is that the
enzyme that does the carbon fixation it
can also react with oxygen and when
oxygen essentially reacts with your
rival OHS by phosphate instead of your
carbon you get an unproductive reaction
not only is an unproductive it'll
actually suck up your ATP in your NADPH
and you'll go nowhere so every now and
then when an oxygen bonds here instead
of a carbon dioxide you get you get
nothing produce a net net everything
becomes less efficient and so in in the
the very in the I think it was exactly
the last video we saw that some plants
have evolu they've evolved a way to get
around this and what they do is they fix
their carbon on outsides on cells that
are actually exposed to the air and then
once they fix the carbon and they
actually fix it into a four carbon
molecule into oxaloacetate and then they
put and that gets turned into malli then
they pump the malate deeper within the
leaf where you don't you aren't exposed
to oxygen and then they take the carbon
dioxide off the malate and this is where
they actually perform the calvin cycle
and even though you do have your abisco
still there your abisco isn't going to
have the photo respiration is not going
to occur because it only has access to
carbon dioxide it does not have access
to this oxygen out here now and that's a
very efficient way of producing sugars
and that's why some of the plants that
we associate with being very strong
sugar or even you know ethanol producers
all perform c4 photosynthesis a corn
sugar I could write these down corn
sugar cane sugar cane and and crabgrass
and these are all very very efficient
sugar producers because they don't have
to worry too much about photorespiration
now some plants have a slightly
different problem they're not so worried
about the efficiency of the process
they're more worried about losing water
and you can imagine what plants these
are these are plants that are in the
desert because these stomata these pores
that are on the leaves they let in they
let in air but they can also
let out water right I mean if I'm in the
rainforest I don't care about that but
if I'm in the middle of the desert I
don't want to let out water vapor
through my stomata so the ideal
situation is I would want my stomata
closed during the daytime right this is
what I want so I want if I'm in the
desert let me make this clear if I'm in
the desert
I want stomata closed
I want stomata closed during the day
right for obvious reasons I don't want
all my water to vaporize out of these
holes in my leaf but at the same time
but the problem is that photosynthesis
can only occur during the daytime and
that includes the dark reactions
remember I've said multiple times the
dark reactions are badly named they're
more like the light independent
reactions but they both occur
simultaneously the light independent and
light dependent and only during the
daytime so photosynthesis photosynthesis
synthesis only at day and if your
stomata are is closed you need I mean
you know to perform photosynthesis
especially the Calvin cycle you need co2
so how can you get around this if I want
to close my stomata during the day but I
need co2 during the day how can I solve
this problem and what what desert plants
or many desert plants have evolved to do
essentially does photosynthesis but
instead of fixing instead of fixing the
carbon in outer cells and then pushing
it into inner cells and then performing
the Calvin cycle they do it instead of
outer and inner cells they do it at the
night time and in the daytime so in camp
plants and these are called camp plants
because I could tell you what it stands
for it stands for Kraft soul a.cian acid
metabolism and that's because it was
first observed and that in that species
of plants the crassulacean plant but
these are just called you know you could
call it cam photosynthesis or cam plants
they're essentially a subset of c4
plants but instead of performing c4
photosynthesis kind of an outside cells
and inside cells they do it at the night
time in the day so they're subset
of c-4 plants or c4 photosynthetic
plants and what they do is at night
maybe at night they keep their stomata
open they keep their stomata open and
they perform they keep their stomata
open and they're able to fix so and this
everything occurs in the mesophyll cells
and the cam cells and the cam plants so
in the date at the night time when
they're not afraid of losing water so
let's say this is a mesophyll cell right
here my stomata is open let's say that
this is my stomata right there and so it
lets in carbon dioxide I'm not worried
about losing water vapor it's night time
right now so carbon dioxide comes in
here and then it fixes the carbon
dioxide it fixes it the exact same way
that the c4 plants do so you have your
co2 come in CEO 2 you have your pep you
have your pep it's all facilitated by
pep carboxylase that's the enzyme that
can only fix co2 that can only react
with co2 not with oxygen and then that
is used to produce and we saw it here in
our cam 4 and our cam 4 diagram in the
last video that is to use to produce
malate this for carbon of four carbon
molecule so that is used to produce
malate and then the malate and then this
is what's key the malate gets stored in
other organelles in the cell and
vacuoles which are you can kind of view
them as large storage containers in the
cell so I drew this as the whole cell I
mean this is actually all occuring you
know it in in your in your chloroplast
but you could imagine your cell having a
big storage set center where the malate
gets stored at night and you can view
malate is almost you know it's like a
carbon dioxide store because later on we
can access the malate and get the carbon
dioxide and that's exactly what these
cam plants are going to do so this is
nighttime then the Sun comes up so now
we're in the daytime
this desert plant well maybe it's a
cactus it doesn't want to lose its water
vapor so it's closes its stomata so it's
closed it's the stoma this particular
Stormo now
is closed it's now closed and you say oh
boy how's it going to perform
photosynthesis well it can perform
photosynthesis in that very same cell in
that very same cell because it stored up
all of this malate at night and so now
the malate can be pumped out of the
vacuoles into the stroma of our
chloroplast and then this that you can
have the pyruvate break off but the more
important thing is you have co2 break
off so you have a ready supply of co2
and now we can from warm our standard
calvin cycle in an environment only with
co2 our stomata our stoma is closed so
we're ready to go our co2 reacts with
ribulose biphosphate and then catalyzed
by Rubisco it's the whole calvin cycle
and we produce our sugar so this is this
is kind of a neat adaptation in these hi
very efficient sugar producing plants
that aren't that worried about water
they do they perform carbon fixation on
the on things that are exposed to the
air and then they they pump kind of a
stored version of the carbon deeper into
the leaf to actually perform the calvin
cycle so that you it's not la C so that
photorespiration doesn't occur because
it down here you have no oxygen the
desert plants I mean they benefit from
that property as well but their whole
concern is I don't want to keep my store
model open in the daytime so what I do
is I fix my carbon at night but I use
the exact same process but the process I
use pep carboxylase and I store it I
store my carbon dioxide at night and
then the daytime in the daytime I can
actually when you know my light
reactions my light dependent reactions
are occurring and they're producing my
ATP in my NADH I can also perform my
dark reactions and the daytime as I said
the dark reactions always occur in the
daytime or my light independent
reactions because even though my stomata
is closed I have a store of carbon
dioxide in the form of malate